anywhere there is like this thing about
the
solution is not clear
and the common wisdom is something which
is uh
not the
uh really the
truth
then it it really gets me to dig deeper
and uh keeps my
thought process active and uh you know
inspiration flowing
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel an in media
partnership with ctek
hello and welcome to another episode of
20 minute leaders today i'm joined by
raj kumar venkatesan the ronald
trezinski professor of business
administration at the darden business
school at the university of virginia raj
has written about and taught
quantitative marketing to mba and
executive education students worldwide
at darden he has taught a course on
marketing analytics for more than 10
years and a course on marketing
technology products for five years his
experience in these courses has
translated into books cutting edge
marketing analytics published by pearson
education in 2014 and ai marketing
canvas in 2021 he has published
extensively in the journal of marketing
journal of marketing research marketing
science journal of academy of marketing
science international journal of
research and marketing harvard business
review and california management review
he serves as an associate editor for
journal of marketing international
journal of research and marketing and
journal of academy of marketing science
more than 250 000 individuals have
participated in his coursera course on
marketing analytics
raj venkatest and welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
very good thank you for having me
michael it's a great pleasure to meet
you thank you very very much for being
here raj you're the professor of
business administration at the darden
business school university of virginia
you've written numerous books cutting
edge marketing analytics ai marketing
canvas
you've published extensively in
different journals and most impressive
to me as an avid coursera
you know learner and you've had more
than 250 000 individuals that have
participated in your coursera course on
marketing analytics i think that's just
incredible
you know this idea that you can create
some some educational program that
reaches this number of students did you
expect so many students to be taking
this course
no no
in fact not a thought and this shows to
the power of uh
online platforms and the reach that they
have
and it's it's it's an incredible uh
journey and
i'm fortunate to have so many students
subscribe to the course and uh
fortunate that the message i wanted in
the course is able to reach a wide
audience all over the world
incredible incredible well uh
so you know the andrew ing is a friend
from from stanford and i had the
pleasure of taking a few classes with
him and i resonate when he speaks about
his you know experience and and building
coursera with exactly this in mind raj
take me back a little bit through your
career and and will converge on this
idea of of artificial intelligence as a
strategy within companies tell me a
little bit about your career and how
you've gotten to to this conviction that
you have around around this technology
so i started with the my undergrad
education was in computer engineering
and uh this was in the mid 90s and i was
learning at that time about all this new
technology that was coming up around
like neural networks and genetic
algorithms and that's where i
my first exposure was and at that time
it was still theoretical this was not
something that would like you know
nobody knew it would scale and
i found my way to business school
where uh the faculty felt that um there
would be an application of this in the
future and they were very patient about
this and asked me if i would be
interested in pursuing a career in
marketing and
i started thinking some courses i liked
it and i actually found that i can now
apply some of the you know concepts
algorithms that you just learned
with a real problem and application that
was motivating and interesting for me
and i like human psychology and
understanding about consumers and data
that was more like relevant i felt like
the data spoke to me when it was about
people and their behaviors
and so i
really started enjoying it and
worked more on that
and so
that's kind of what one thing led to the
other in terms of my research was always
focused on using technology and
marketing
and i've got
over there i've seen the evolution from
the mid 90s to now
with like the old erp systems to crm
systems to mobile to now
ai and that's been an incredible journey
to see the two worlds actually converge
and
what is now possible with the ai in
marketing
so can you give me a few examples of how
technology comes into play with
marketing you know in the last decade or
two and how that has made a a
significant transformation that is
perhaps not not as trivial as you know
the the average entrepreneur may
understand it to be
yes so there is a quote by john lester
on
art and technology which talks about how
art inspires technology and technology
inspires art and i think that that's
true for even marketing even from the
very beginning uh you said 10 to 20
years i'll take you back like maybe 80
years where that first television
started and how our commercials were
beginning and that was the technology of
the time
and you could see marketing embrace that
immediately and but at that time you had
like one campaign that you would have
for everybody and then over time as
cable started you started seeing
segmentation and you started seeing like
maybe two or three segments
and with like in the 80s really you had
direct mail that started and
with some amount of database technology
that was picking up and you had
companies like capital one that were
like doing massive a b testing on direct
mail campaigns and like finding out like
what kind of message works for which uh
consumer for you know balance transfer
or better interest rates
and that was like in the 80s right and
then
you can see digital really start around
and this whole email campaigns and
search engine started looking at like
1000 different segments and so you can
see that marketing has always been using
technology
to
cater and target to personalized
individuals in a personalized way
and now with ai you can see with like
the starbucks loyalty program app that
has about
close to 20 million
consumers on the app are now able to
send personalized recommendations and
offers to you based on what like coffee
or tea you like
and and also promote products identify
like if you're launching a new pumpkin
spice ladder who's going to like it and
so
you can see for me
uh technology has really allowed
marketing to get more personalized
at scale
right and so what what has happened in
the last
you know five to ten years with the
explosion of artificial intelligence
beyond just you know the technology that
we're discussing how has that made an
even more significant leap in the world
of marketing
yeah great question i think um
one is i start with the notion in my
class always that and we talked about in
the book also is
before ai you knew
like you know the marketing funnel is
awareness interest desire and action you
knew about consumers till they bought
the product
you didn't know about how they use the
product right and you would try some
focus groups or like you know i like the
example of cars where like you know if
you bought a car like a toyota
once you bought the car toyota doesn't
know how you're using it until you go to
the service
and that's why service networks are so
important now if you look at tesla and
all the technology of all the
technology-enabled cars and tesla's at
the forefront there but other cars also
have like this smart technology they can
tell how you're using the car and for
what purposes and with the smartphone
apps also you're able to see how
consumers use the app like when i create
it to my car in the morning it tells me
how much uh traffic is for my work right
and
so it tells me that i'm taking it for
long distances or just for back and
forth for work or am i picking up kids
in the evening so all of this
information allows then the companies to
start customizing the cars in terms of
what needs i have right and what kind of
uh how big each segment is and that is
really the difference with ai i feel is
that the knowledge about how we use
products
and how we talk about these products
with others
and that's the gold and
it's like information that is gold for
marketers
right now obviously this is you know if
we're looking at incumbents and we're
looking at companies that are already
existing and they're you know observing
this explosion of technology and you
know perhaps they even have a few dozen
people on marketing or even a few
hundred people on marketing
how have they adapted so i can get why
you know an early stage company a new
startup that starts out will immediately
want to take them the most advanced
technology and will understand it but
how does a big company
can go ahead and you know integrate a
similar technology like this into their
pipeline with with all that you know it
takes to do that
yeah excellent observation and that was
in fact our main motivation for writing
the book ai marketing canvas is
to see there's a lot of uh digital
platforms and digital natives that are
disrupting markets and how are incumbent
brands like
really reacting to this and how can they
benefit and what we saw where like there
are two examples we give i can pick two
examples from the police one is on um
chase uh what they did with the the
retail banking uh advertising so they
use this vendor prasado which does
emotion ai
and they now have signed with them um
a full contract to for prasada to
actually write the digital campaigns
it's not just who sees it and what the
offer is it is actually the
copy of the ad is written by the machine
and the reason was that
chase felt that it's very ironic stories
because the chase felt that because
there were more atms and mobile apps
were getting better people are not going
to the retail bank so they were not able
to get
an emotional connection with the brand
so they needed to have the ads speak
to the consumers in a more emotional way
to connect with the consumers but to do
that at scale you need a machine
so that's what they did with uh so that
was their first experiment they started
with a few
experiments then the roi was well there
so now they've signed for all of the
digital campaigns to be run by
machines
incredible that's one example of a
really old
great brand using ai yeah and coke has
done that too with their uh
smart vending machines they because they
have iot's on all the vending machines
uh that we can customize the drinks and
so they know one is of course they know
how much uh for sprite or cherry or coke
is being used to need different vending
machines so they can avoid stockholders
which is important for customer
relationships but also they found that
sprite cherry was the drink a lot of us
actually combined on that smart vending
machine so this insight from the vending
machine uh told them to launch it in the
grocery stores
and which was the one of the biggest uh
recent hits so you can see um
coke actually investing like we talked
about the consumption period for
actually investing in these smart
vending machines to directly understand
how consumers are using its brand and
like the benefits then it provides them
with new product innovation
can you tell me a little bit about what
it's like being a professor in this
field and you know researching it from
the side sharing it with students
writing case studies what was that what
is this process like for you as a
thinker
and you know looking at it and you know
experiencing it both on the theoretical
way but also in the more very very
practical way
it's an incredible uh
journey and it's uh
very exhilarating because
the field keeps changing every day
so and even you learn from the students
too in the classroom because they really
are on the forefront of what is going on
like in gaming i'm not a gamer i mean my
children maybe play a few games here and
there but i'm not an avid gamer but you
know we had a discussion around
augmented reality in retail in the class
last week and teaching digital marketing
and
there was a very interesting discussion
because uh it was about like how brands
are using digital skins like burberry
and louis vuitton luxury brands are
reaching consumers using digital skins
and there was a really great
debate in the class on
one group of students saying why would a
luxury brand get into gaming they're
diluting the brand there's another group
saying uh well it's actually a great
idea because a lot of people spend
i mean people are willing to spend a lot
of money for digital skins and this is
actually a good placement even if it
doesn't lead to sale in the store the
brand awareness and also the sale of
digital skin itself is valuable for
these brands so i mean i didn't even i
mean you know this is something that i
learned a lot from that discussion and
also
that's the best part about this is you
are
learning every day and that's what makes
it a lot of fun for me
now as you're writing books about this
topic
and you're really actively
trying to dissect you know from case
studies and bring them together into
some greater trends and predictions
you know how how does this process look
like is it simply you know
really diving deep researching into case
studies and putting together like do you
find yourself pondering over these
theories and trying to come up with
these convictions how do you work
specifically
so it's a combination it's almost it's
like a portfolio so uh we in done we
write we teach you the case method so
there is a a lot of case development
work that par is part of my day job
itself so i'm writing a case study on a
fitness
tracker company and how they should
expand and so that's i'm learning a lot
about that industry as well as the
technology about like fitness tracking
and health and
fitness as such but also i'm doing
research on how
you know gdpr affects the returns from
acquisitions that are ai related and
should companies still focus given all
these privacy regulations and that's
more empirical data driven
and so all of that ads so what we try to
do is i try to focus on the area of ai
but
there are different
you can go in industry deep dives using
case studies uh the book was more about
a collection of case studies and then
you put it together as theory and then
the research ends up being more deep
empirical testing of the theory to see
like what are the boundary conditions of
this theory
taking back a little bit to your
childhood and you know middle school
elementary school
you know are you always fascinated with
these things is it always about this
intersection of technology psychology
consumer behavior
how how companies work or or was it
other things what really led to this
so i was always interested in technology
i i mean it was just fascinating i still
remember the first time i uh saw a
machine in like i mean it was like a
demo right i mean that this was in the
early 90s and we didn't have like in
india all the mission pcs all over in in
our houses so i saw it in like a school
or some place where there were like 20
students uh
looking at this one machine that was
running on ms dos and that was like the
biggest fascination
and uh and basic was the language at
that time and i started i liked it i
wanted to do more in it and definitely i
stuck around with that but uh consumer
behavior as such was not something i was
really into or marketing because
india was just opening up at that time
so the consumer culture also just
beginning and so i was more focused on
engineering and that was pretty much
what i was doing
uh i mean i was into sports and you know
so all of that was definitely on like
any
uh person growing up in india i was into
cricket and you know for and at that
time it was not a great encouraging time
to be a cricket fan as it is now with
the indian teams doing much better but
that was pretty much my life i think but
the technology stream definitely stayed
alone
if you're fast forwarding to today and
you're looking at your work and you're
continuing to dive deep and do this
research and work with students where do
you draw your inspiration from today
both you know professionally and
personally
inspiration is certainly from what's
happening around us that is certainly my
inspiration and
you know i
i
like podcasts like this i hear a lot
about like the world around ai and the
intersection of human and ai and general
uh ai and gpt3 and
you know i'm really fascinated by this
question of like how would the world be
when there is a lot of ai and not just
like general purpose right it's not just
like what i'm talking about in this book
as and
also about social issues around
uh you know
with social media and how as consumers
do we uh
how does it shape our society as such
right in terms of
the information bubbles versus
effect on our health and
but at the same time it is allowing for
information to pass and
people to organize
and so there's this interesting uh
challenge that you have of good and bad
right and even with like climate change
then there is this it's not easy to
crack this puzzle because any time you
go down one part it has some negative
externalities in another place right so
those things really fascinate me and
keep me uh you know that really is the
inspiration for me really is around you
know do you do regulations how what are
the effect of uh all of these big uh
tech uh platforms on society
and so anywhere there is like this thing
about that
solution is not clear
and the common wisdom is something which
is uh
not the
uh really the
truth then it it really gets me to dig
deeper and
keeps my uh
thought process active and uh you know
inspiration flowing
i love it and if there were a few words
that you had to choose for yourself or
if i were to ask anybody that knows you
really really well
who's raj what what what do some words
come to mind
yeah well i should qualify that you know
if anybody knew what others would tell
about them that's like uh
i want to know the secret
so what i would like for people to know
i can say like yeah curious kind
sympathetic
and
uh casual and chill i think that would
what i would
think of me as
raj thank you so much for the time this
was so enjoyable and i love i love the
work that you're doing and these
questions that you're posing are so
interesting and and they're so
ridiculously relevant to everything
that's been happening especially
especially in this last year and a half
i can only imagine you know the world is
becoming so digitalized and globalized
throughout the pandemic you know the the
data scientist in me is you know
scrambling to look for new data sets and
to figure out okay how is consumer
behavior shifting
and how are companies adapting
especially as so many businesses
were forced to shift from physical to
online and and that just draws on on
infinite opportunity exactly in the
worlds that you're talking about and i
look forward to checking out the
coursera course myself i can't believe
you have 250 000 students that's just
freaking amazing that's that's
incredible
and saraj thank you very very much for
your time and stay safe and stay healthy
thank you
[Music]